de los 22 años y medio se ven pasar a 15
en prisión y siete años y medio en
detención domiciliaria y le descontaron
199 días que ha durado el juicio la
sentencia del juez de minnesota peter
que estuvo en línea con lo que los
expertos legales esperaban a pesar de
que los abogados de la familia de
georges floyd pedían que la pena fuera
de 30 años el caso de joven sin embargo
está lejos de terminarse ya que él y su
abogado tienen 90 días para apelar la
decisión algo que expertos legales dan
como un hecho en cualquier caso pérez
joven se convierte en el decimoprimer
policía en servicio el ser sentenciado
por homicidio desde el 2005 siendo 40
años la pena más grande que obtuvo un
policía por homicidio en servicio al
respecto el presidente yo by the end
reaccionó brevemente diciendo que la
sentencia le parecía apropiado